what an ordeal another five weeks till
the elections pashtun books poll ratings
are poor he has to fight for every vote
every where pêche Stein book has to
visit the cow barn
you
pash tyne book has to take to the
streets
cashtown book has to visit the shipyard
Josh Stein book is running for
Chancellor
pash tyne book at a hip gallery in
berlin's quoits burg district he wants
to govern Germany and this is how he
pitches it bonhams françoise's yep till
mid-september 22nd we want a new
chancellor one who won't demand too
little from this Republic who won't love
it to sleep but we'll gather together
all those who have an interest in this
Republic a chancellor who will leave or
deafhood and then underly analyst
general secretary of the Social
Democrats explains how she expects the
SPD to beat the popular current
Chancellor air why we want to conduct
the most modern campaign of any party in
Germany the SPD's version of a modern
campaign posting election placards
canvassing neighborhoods giving big
speeches in big cities Stein book begins
where he feels secure his own electoral
district in the town of mech none in the
Rhineland the local farmers association
has invited him to visit a dairy farm
dd+ have prices increased again yes and
the last half-year prices have been
rising again the candidate is striving
for a down-to-earth image but he often
seems chilly and aloof to hear something
personal you have to ask this VOSH
ptaszek in later when we had children we
often vacationed on the farm four or
five times he balloting I admit not in
North rhine-westphalia but in the Al
Gore region did you milk the cows I'd s
hobbies my Fez I tried to and realize
that it's very strenuous and you need a
certain technique I damaged him
technique big off as passe une United in
person he's a pleasant guy this is the
first time I met him personally I have a
good impression he's direct and speaks
openly and listens often this wall and
often as a wire will you vote for him
does i'll have to see
from the stable to the streets
Steinbrueck wants to talk with people so
he starts out by himself Social
Democrats want to recover their image as
the party that addresses people's
problems I've been to your place before
yes a number of times you've forgotten
no I have a good memory bend if he
becomes Chancellor then things will
start moving will he be elected I hope
so I think he's good but he's in the
wrong party that's probably how many
people here think Stein book in the m's
length region a Christian Democrat
stronghold time book gets along fine
with mr. Maya the head of the Maya
shipyard the SPD Chancellor candidate is
considered business-friendly during the
campaign he poses for pictures with the
apprentices the cruise ship factory is
right up his alley he's happy to answer
questions from the journalists for
example what shipbuilding and politics
have in common in fights here they not
only understand complexity they master
complexity and it's similar in politics
and that's the answer you want to hear
and what do the workers want to hear
ideas for economically languishing
regions that's really important for us
in this region a lot of jobs depend on
it let's hope he does something about it
for us finds it and would you vote for
him and I'll look at the whole picture
small talk in the stalls in a cafe and
in the shipyard that's one thing a
rousing campaign speech is another and
that's pastime books world
exactly Christian Democrats can't handle
money if they govern the desert there'd
be a shortage of sand Hamburg the first
big rally for the Social Democrats
paradigm crooks golds the governing
coalition and promises secure pensions a
minimum wage childcare and fair rents
the rest is business as usual the
candidate lets the gruff somewhat
abrasive northern German peek through
Matt was it a side note of it as voters
gitana who has done something and
especially who has not done something in
the last four years Steinbrueck talks
about past mistakes including his own
some verbal gaffes that cost him
popularity you're going to nights we
want to carry out politics with content
and that sometimes rubs people the wrong
way some of my remarks might be
provocative but at least you know where
you stand with me is Venus as Fonzie
mitten isn't whether that leads people
to vote for him is another question the
polls don't look good there are still
five weeks of campaigning five more
weeks for pashtun hook to turn things
around